pour en parler en direct avec une pierre
guerlain professeur émérite de
civilisation américaine à l'université
paris ouest nanterre et spécialiste des
états unis bonjour merci d'être avec
nous alors la france perd beaucoup avec
ce contrat parce que finalement il a un
double enjeu économique et géopolitique
et c'est sur cet aspect là que ça fait
grincer des dents
oui tout à fait ce que montre cet
échange récent c'est que les grandes
puissances ne s'occupent pas de leurs
alliés la même mésaventure était arrivée
à la grande-bretagne moment de la guerre
en irak lorsque les états unis ne se
soucie pas d'un allié ne le font pas et
il faut voir que mac fait ce n'est pas
la devise uniquement deux clubs c'est la
devise de la plupart des présidents
américains et donc là c'est tout à fait
inédit gants entre alliés mais c'est pas
tout à fait inhabituel
alors l'otan est clair en cela n'aura
pas d'impact sur la coopération
militaire au sein le temps ce sont les
propos de l'amiral roboearth et le
président du comité militaire de l'otan
est-ce qu'il se veut rassurant puisque
on sait que jean yves le drian n'a pas
tout à fait distinctes puisque selon lui
ça va peser justement sur la définition
du nouveau concept de l'alliance
il est clair qu'il y a des désaccords
importants au sein de l'otan il du reste
macron avait dit il ya très peu de temps
c'est une organisation qui était un état
de mort cérébrale et il est aussi
mécontent de la façon dont les années
n'ont pas été consultés pour le retrait
d'afghanistan dont il ya énormément de
conflits qui implique surtout la france
et les pays anglo américain glow sexe
l'otan a du souci à se faire
alors c'est pas si l'otan a du souci à
se faire parce que même avec ce qui
vient de se passer la puissance
américaine ares ce qu'elle est là je
regardais il ya quelques jours un
entretien avec john thain qui est un des
plus grands spécialisé relations
internationales aux états unis et il
expliqué à son public australien que
l'australie n'avait pas le choix de
s'aligner par exemple de se rapprocher
de la chine parce que à ce moment là les
etats unis lui ferait payer très cher
donc là on peut penser que cette
histoire c'est une pression américaine
très fort que la soie l australie soit
non seulement dans un gros ce nouveau
rôle mais aussi achètent des armes
américaines le militaire sert à faire
des affaires
alors justement on arme entretien
téléphonique entre joe biden et emmanuel
ma points donc quelques jours on imagine
qu'ils vont essayer d'arranger les
choses à ce qu'on peut y croire
là on va y avoir certainement de belles
paroles mais il faut aussi être réaliste
la france qui est une puissance très
moyenne à très peu d'atouts vers les
puissances moyennes qui arrive à faire
céder les états unis et israël ou
l'arabie saoudite et dans une moindre
mesure l'allemagne qui a réussi à faire
changer des états unis de points de vue
sur le gazoduc north stream 2 mais la
france a quelques atouts mais beaucoup
moins que ces pays pour faire changer
les états unis de l'opinion dont on peut
supposer qu'il y avoir de belles paroles
et puis le un rabibochage qui sera
passera peut-être par les quelques
centaines de millions de dhs et de
dédommagement pour la rupture du contrat
est ce que dans quelques semaines puis
tout quelques mois est ce que finalement
ce sera un couac diplomatique dont on va
enfin qu'on va oublier
ce sera un couac diplomatique mais il ya
quand même des lignes de force qui
montre que plusieurs pays en europe pour
la france est en pointe là dessus c'est
historiquement fréquents mais
le parapluie américain
satisfait de moins en moins les
européens est bon à l'intérieur de
l'europe coupure entre divers pays mais
pour l'otan de l'afghanistan était un
problème comme auparavant le kosovo
avait été un problème donc ces
dissensions continue à exister et ses
dissensions sera appréhendé dans un
cadre de rapports de force très des
phares à favorable aux alliés des etats
unis disposent ni des moyens de
rétorsion énorme militaire comec
commerciaux économiques sur les autres
donc il ya des désaccords qui couve mais
on peut supposer qu'il y aura des
accords de façade conviendront très
rapidement
pierre guerlain merci pour votre
éclairage on rappelle que vous êtes
professeur émérite de civilisation
américaine à l'université paris ouest
nanterre et spécialiste des a's états
unis merci à vous d'avoir été en direct
sur les france